you probably haven't heard but Britain
voted to leave the European Union now
we're going to avoid that argument like
it's the plague and instead ask the
question why did Britain join it in the
first place first of all when Britain
made its application to join the EU in
1961 it didn't exist instead it was the
EC the European communities which would
eventually go on to become the EU and
the important body within this was the
EEC the european economic community
since Britain's primary interest was
economic it consisted of these six
members and some were much less keen
than others on Britain joining more on
that in a bit though so Britain had
previously focused its economic ties
with this remaining Imperial territories
in the Commonwealth yet as these nations
began to shift their focus to other
nations like the United States Britain
had to look for other markets Britain
had originally been opposed to any
formal pan-european organization of
nations that felt that all that was
needed was a free trade agreement these
negotiations for a free trade agreement
fell apart pretty quickly and when these
six nations form the EEC Britain sat it
out instead Britain and these nations
got together and created the EFTA the
European free trade association which
removed some of the barriers to trade
with the EEC and thus Britain now had a
choice either remain as part of the EFTA
known as the seven or applied to join
the EEC known as the six there was
pressure to do this because Britain's
economy wasn't growing as fast as the
rest of Europe's and there was a fear of
being left behind and thus in 1961
British Prime Minister Harold Macmillan
went for membership now applying to join
the EEC didn't guarantee success and for
Britain there were two major obstacles
the first was the United States of
America Britain wanted to be sure that
its membership with the EEC didn't
contravene any American foreign policy
the second and the biggest hurdle was
France specifically president charles de
gaulle and in 1963 he vetoed britain's
entry into the EEC for several reasons
the first was that de Gaulle believed
that Britain joining the EEC would
weaken its ties to the British
Commonwealth which he felt were a vital
parts of containing communism the second
reason was that French United States
relations were pretty poor in the early
1960s and the Sturgill was concerned
that Britain would simply be a means of
America directly affecting the way the
EC works in Tagore's eyes these two
things combined meant that Britain would
never properly commit to Europe in the
way that say France or West Germany had
despite being rejected Britain didn't
give up and instead did everything they
could to make future integration easier
a reason for Britain's continued
interest
was a concern that financially was too
reliant on the United States in 1967
Britain again made an application to
join and again Charles de Gaulle vetoed
it his reason for this was that he felt
the British Pound was too unstable and
that Britain would need to devalue it
before entering the EEC Prime Minister
Harold Wilson didn't want to do that and
so he went on the charm offensive and so
he got the most charming man he could
find Chancellor James Callaghan to write
articles in French newspapers claiming
that the French would eventually come
around to Britain's way of thinking and
let Britain in but from fact no Wilson
for many reasons to volleyed the pound
and so with that - cause primary reason
for not wanting Britain to join was gone
and he vetoed them again this rejection
however was condemned by the other
members of the EEC and to many in
Britain it sort of felt like de Gaulle
simply held a grudge
now Britain not to be defeated had two
clever tricks up its sleeve
number one was time because de Gaulle
wasn't going to be President forever and
sure enough he wasn't number two was
collective bargaining in 1972 Britain
made a joint application with Denmark
Ireland and Norway on the condition that
if Britain didn't get in nobody would
join and this time it was accepted by
everyone except by Norway who then
stayed in the e of T a three years later
Britain held a referendum to confirm
whether or not it would continue its
membership and this was overwhelmingly
backed by the public the European
communities would become the European
Union in 1993 I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching but
thanks to my patreon supporters whom you
can see on screen now and with an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette Ike
Danny Maloney Colin Castleman Marvin
Castle Rob Waterhouse Aaron the white
Jordan long way Chris wicker Gustav
Swann Gareth Turner
Marcus arse nur Maggie pax Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
k-word Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell par shoe 19 and Moe